foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Hunter fighting for president
don't do today what underbody should do
dude I think this is the perfect
solution for him is he should go to
Trump Tower come down the golden
escalator and announce his candidacy for
president and that way he doesn't have
to face any prosecution
makes sense right
I mean just just go ask any idiot in a
manga hat
if running for president stops you from
being prosecuted just go ask him go ask
him they'll tell you
some ridiculous answer about how running
for president keeps you from
going to federal prison or even facing
trial or even being indicted really for
that matter and honestly honestly all
this stuff about Hunter Biden he should
be protected by the presidential records
Act
he should be I think the presidential
records act 100 protects Hunter Biden
from all the gqp's nonsense here I think
it does you know I I I'm not gonna you
know
throw out any rakes to step on because
they're doing enough of it holy actual
[__] yesterday I told you exactly what
was going to happen and it happened
in the morning see this is why I start
my show when I started so that we can
get yesterday's news the weekend news
but the morning narrative and I told you
yesterday
in the very front part of the podcast
you can go back and listen if you want
you can say that I was
right or wrong you're only going to find
that I was correct
that the Devon Archer [__] was all a
bunch of horse crap a big pile of dung
total [__] [__] from Jim Comer
James Jim James Comer and Jim Jordan Jim
I don't report sex crimes Jordan Matt
Getz and the rest of the gqp
that's why they had a closed door
transcripted meeting hearing while Devin
Archer was under oath is because it was
a nothing Burger they knew it was a
nothing Burger because there is no
evidence of any crime anywhere
it's all to distract you
from the fact that their orange
Mussolini Jesus did in fact
did in fact steal
our government documents did in fact
Harbor them at Mar-A-Lago unsecurely and
obstructed the return of those documents
not only that the [__]
absolutely deleted subpoenaed evidence
from his cameras after after the special
counsel doj said yeah we're gonna need
that oh let's go erase it let's go let's
go bleach wash
the camera servers
they're a [__] joke in and of
themselves
it's [__] ridiculous even I'm gonna
show you a clip of Laura Ingraham I
can't
bar Nazi Barbie Laura Ingraham oh my God
you know everyone's been making these
Barbie memes a Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert someone hey can we get
someone to make a Nazi Barbie with
Lauren Graham did you know her dad
had mine comp on her his coffee table
apparently the the Nazi doesn't fall far
from the tree
listen folks Lauren Graham says last
night on Fox News look there doesn't
need to be evidence at all
of Joe Biden committing any crime for us
to think that he's a criminal holy [__]
and you're and you're standing around
wondering why they're still going to
vote for Donald Trump because they're
feeding them buckets buckets and buckets
of [__] stories and [__]
narratives that these people want to
hear
they want to hear it because they hear
it from us all the time that Donald
Trump is a corrupt [__] he's a
criminal he's a liar he's a cheat
and all of his gqp allies all the way
down to Ron [__] DeSantis are a bunch
of criminal cheat crooked line
[__]
and they ain't out for no one but
themselves in their own power
so they have to project it on everyone
else
listen Hunter Biden never took no
bribery payments for Joe Biden it didn't
happen
if it did happen you damn well better
bet they would come with a press
conference yesterday as soon as Devin
Archer said you goddamn right you
goddamn right Joe Biden took bribes but
Devin Archer didn't say it because he
was under oath [__] gonna go to
prison
he doesn't need to go to prison again
so if you're standing around still
wondering why Donald Trump is gonna be
the [__] nominee well you're not
paying attention you're just not paying
attention
these it's we're at the intersection of
WrestleMania and real life these people
want to believe this [__] even if it's
not true they know they need to believe
it
because the only way they can justify
voting for such a [__] pile of
garbage of human trash like Donald Trump
is to say look your guy's trash too
that's it that's the that's what they
have to have to make him their leader
they must have the comparison
because truly objectively when you
compare Donald Trump and Joe Biden the
one thing you gotta notice the
difference is
and I I know it's I know I shouldn't
have to point it out but I'm going to
all the crime that Joe Biden has been
[__] accused of he hasn't he hasn't
tweeted about it once
not [__] once
Joe Biden is not scared of the
Republicans accusing him a crime he did
not commit
are you following me
Donald Trump can't stop criming he can't
stop talking about his crimes he can't
stop making up [__] [__] [__]
legal arguments that have no basis in
any kind of [__] legal fact
whatsoever about his crimes
he can't even stop forcing his attorneys
to debase themselves
to actually write memos and motions in
court that are all [__] legal
arguments that get shot down every time
because he's a [__] loser this is how
losers Act
and when you're on the losing team and
you know you're not gonna win the best
thing that you can do is just yell and
scream from the stands and try to
distract the team that is doing their
job
that's it
it's what this is they know it
they know it
do you think these people actually
believe some of this [__] maybe a few of
them maybe a few do
they don't believe this [__]
they cannot turn back now
they are in too deep
they are not going to be wrong that is
one thing that you can guarantee with
white Christian nationalists
one thing you can ensure about them they
are never no matter how no matter how
ignorant they look
no matter how delusional it may seem
they are never going to back down from
them being correct
they have to be
they are infallible they are superior
it's the basis of their entire ideology
is superiority
how could they possibly be wrong
even when they know that the facts are
against them
[__] them let them keep throwing out the
rakes and step on them
[__] them
yesterday when America woke up no one
knew who Devin Archer was the gqp Jim
Comer and Jim Jordan's mission is to
exonerate Donald Trump by accusing Joe
Biden of some stupid [__] bribe that
never happened
with Devin Archer and yesterday America
went to bed and still doesn't know who
Devin Archer is
and the people who were paying attention
yesterday are [__] laughing at the
House Republicans because they are so
inept
they could be doing so many things like
hey hey you [__] idiots you got
elected to lower gas prices what are you
doing on that not a God damn thing
they aren't doing a goddamn thing about
inflation they aren't doing a goddamn
thing about gas prices not a God damn
thing
because they can't stop thinking about
Hunter Biden's huge ass hog
Jesus Christ they're holding up pictures
of it and committee hearings they're so
[__] obsessed with Hunter Biden's
dick
I just I want them to release the
transcript from yesterday because I want
them to I want to see if they ask about
his [__]
I almost guaran damned to you there was
a [__] there was a [__] question
about Hunter Biden getting his dick out
and taking a picture of it
to Devin Archer Garen goddamn tea it
doubt me [__] doubt me
I I wonder how many times they said the
[__] word laptop yesterday
Daniel Goldman was in the hearing
yesterday
and you could tell you could tell
ah Daniel Goldman he's so he was he was
I think he was really disappointed that
this wasn't an open committee
like I I know I know the Democrats
wanted this one close to
right
I I know they wanted this one close too
but listen
it is a hundred percent
a hundred percent for sure
that Daniel Goldman was disappointed
that this was not an open and open
hearing and the reason why it and the
reason why Republic I told you Jesus
yesterday the reason why Republicans
didn't want this in open hearing is
because they knew that this would all
Crash and Burn
they were they if they released this
transcript I wish to hit the [__]
video of it but it's only transcribed
but if they had the video of this this
would totally piss off all the hunter
Biden Lambda people you know the ones
I'm talking about
the one in your [__] Twitter chat and
your replies
the trolls that come out you're like
wait what about the laptop better slam
tap you know the [__] kind I'm
talking about
it would totally [__] bash up every
single and they would be pissed they
would be pissed
at the Republicans because folks even
even if the Republicans can't Deliver Us
low grass gas prices like they
campaigned on and they promised their
stupid [__] constituents as if
Congress controls the gas prices or
something
even if they could do something like
that there's one thing they sure as hell
can't do
they can't
stop with the hunter by narrative
if they stop at the 100 by narrative
they will they will lose their base
they will turn on them
and that's that's the thing here is the
tail is wagging the dog
why do you think we can't stop talking
about [__] Hunter Biden in this
country
they truly want it out front
as if he's running for president and
again I think Connor Biden should
Hunter Biden should go run for president
in the green party or or the libertarian
party or what whatever hell he could you
know what he should start the laptop
party
the laptop party
I mean why not
he could probably attract a lot of these
trolls that hate him now I mean they
probably think he's super cool and
Secret
having sex with prostitutes doing blow
renting houses in San Diego with water
slides do a naked slip and slides with a
bunch of prostitutes
having sex all over the world doing
drugs listening to rock and roll
come on folks
they can't make Hunter Biden sound any
cooler
I mean Jesus Christ he's he's a he's a
drug addict sex addict who loves his
guns
and now he's got a stupid [__]
federal gun charge that he's possibly
gonna face
and you know what as far as Hunter
Biden's federal charges are concerned if
I was Hunter Biden his attorneys I tell
Weiss the U.S attorney in Delaware to go
[__] himself you go [__] yourself take
me to trial [__]
what could possibly be worse for Hunter
Biden than going to trial on of [__]
tax evasion of where he's already paid
the [__] money
he's already paid the money and some
stupid [__] low-level felony gun
charge that any two-way bro should be
pissed off about in this country
you know her you can't infringe your my
rats well I want you to infringe on
Hunter Biden's rights then you're not
serious about [__] the Second
Amendment bro
you're not serious about it about it
being in infringible
you can't he can't take away my it's a
god-given rat it's not god-given
felons all over this country don't have
the right to even touch a gun you stupid
[__]
and you want Hunter Biden to face one of
the stupidest [__] gun charges there
are I think it's dumb
I think it's absolutely ridiculous that
if we have the Second Amendment someone
someone who does drugs can't possess a
gun
what the [__] what the [__] are we doing
maybe maybe what we should do is rethink
the second amendment huh
absolutely [__] ridiculous but
they're not gonna do that they're not
gonna they're not gonna get on the side
of Hunter Biden again because it goes
back to the cult has to be correct
they can't be wrong no matter what lie
they have to tell no matter how how
[__] intricate the stupid [__]
plot that is slipping through their Nazi
fingers is
I watch Jim Jordan I'm going to show you
some clips I know I gotta show you this
[__] Jim I I don't want to but I don't
[__] get to make this [__] up
I don't get to I don't get to be inept
in Congress they do and then I show it
to you and then you have to take action
on their
incompetency by running elections
against their dumb asses so we can
[__] make someone who's interested in
policy and governing in charge of our
[__] government like Hakeem Jeffries
for crying out [__] loud
I don't get to make this [__] up we just
gotta politicize the [__] out of it so
we can win the [__] house and more
senators and state reps and state
Governors and get this [__] over with
get these [__] to crawl back
underneath their goddamn Rock these are
not serious people they're not serious
about our country they're not [__]
Patriots they don't give a [__] about
their constituents they definitely don't
give a [__] about Americans and ain't
don't give a [__] about anything but
their own goddamn power that's it period
[__] period
and you don't have to look any further
than Donald Trump's presidential
campaign to try to keep himself out of
federal prison
and it is our job our job to pay the
[__] attention
and make other people pay the [__]
attention to what the hell is going on
and more importantly what's not going on
which is seriousness in our Congress
making up some stupid story about the
doj wanting to arrest Devin Archer
before he can testify to what
I don't know if you've seen the clip of
Andy Biggs but Andy Biggs an
insurrectionist
an insurrectionist Andy Biggs someone
who wanted to overturn the government to
make Donald Trump the [__] King
said yesterday after the hearing after
the testimony he said yeah this is
[__] nothing [__] nothing nothing
Burger
might as well not even had the testimony
done
is basically what and Annie Biggs is so
ashamed so ashamed that he couldn't even
hardly say it out loud
[__] you Andy [__] you you need to go
it's time that Jim Comer Jim Jordan Andy
Biggs Matt gatz Lauren bobert Marjorie
Taylor green and all their ilk resign
every [__] last one of them they're
inept
at least at least focus on your stupid
ass narrative about gas prices maybe
America will think you give a [__] about
them
huh how about that you [__] pieces of
trash
what do you want from me everyone wants
the Tony rant so there you go there you
have it on Hunter Biden
oh baby release the transcript you
[__] pieces of sludge release the
transcript I don't know if you have
social media but if you do have social
media that's all you need to say to
every single one of these [__] idiots
it was a perfect it was perfect
testimony for Hunter Biden released the
transcript perfect testimony for Hunter
Biden released the transcript hey hey
you troll it was perfect testimony for
Hunter Biden release the transcript I
told you yesterday they're never going
to release that transcript and they
never will they won't do it
they won't they can't they can't do it
it says the opposite of what the
narrative is that they want
I knew it would be that's why they did
it in a closed door hearing
and they're gonna say some stupid [__]
like oh it's way too sensitive the
information in the transcript is way too
sensitive to release just take our word
for it just take our word for it oh and
and an interview will say well does it
show evidence that Joe Biden committed
crime well not yet not yet but we're
getting there oh we're getting there to
the evidence that Joe Biden is a
criminal I can't wait for their
impeachment inquiry
holy [__] bring it on you stupid
[__] Bring It On throw that
rake out there can you imagine can you
[__] imagine if they bring you know
the reason why they don't bring an
impeachment Choir in heaven yet right
you know the reason does anyone know the
reason here the reason why is because
they'll fail
they'll fail to bring impeachment that's
right it won't work they don't have
anything that the American people will
buy that they're actually going to
impeach him
I mean yeah the manga cult but the manga
cult only makes up 12 maybe 15 of the
country and there's another 10 or 15
percent that will go along with their
[__] even though they know it's
[__]
and they know those people are out of
their [__] minds there's no way you
can convince me that there's average
people out there who will vote for Trump
who watch people at the Trump rally and
go these people are [__] nuts I can't
even believe I support this fool but God
damn
so don't get it twisted
but let them impeach him go ahead Kevin
McCarthy have the impeachment acquired
today let's do it you've had you've had
two goddamn years to gather up the
evidence that Joe Biden is some kind of
criminal
you had two more than two goddamn years
Weiss had five years really to gather up
the evidence against Hunter Biden
do it [__] do it
throw that rake out there and jump on it
you dumb [__] do it
that's what we should encourage them to
do
it was the perfect testimony for Hunter
Biden release the transcript say it over
and over and over and over and over
again the perfect testimony for Hunter
Biden release the transcript [__] we
should be chanting it at [__]
gatherings
release the transcript release the
transcript perfect testimony over and
over and over and over again
if they want to be obsessed with Hunter
Biden's [__]
if that's their platform okay whatever
go for it let's do it let's politicize
the issues like I'm gonna do every
single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific right here on YouTube
don't forget to hit the Subscribe button
I'm trying to get better at this YouTube
stuff some people are saying that the
chat is glitchy
it is glitchy on YouTube this morning
it's not you it's them
it's the typical it's not you it's me
but no it's it's YouTube YouTube's fault
they're kind of glitchy so if you want
you can close the chat and reopen it and
come back in if it's glitchy for you
apparently YouTube is having trouble
this morning with their chat
so or or what you can do is Hop on over
to Twitch go to twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels that's what you should be doing
go over to twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels join the chat over there
if you don't want a glitchy chat I don't
think the chance glitchy over there
today
so go follow us there it's free to
follow us on Twitch
also you can use your Amazon Prime
account to link it to your Twitch
account and you can give us a couple
bucks every single month and it doesn't
cost you a single extra dime that's
right
if you link your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account and you give us the
one free subscription you get with
Amazon gaming we get a couple bucks of
Amazon's money every single month twitch
sends it to us so go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com and you can find the
instructions on how to link your Amazon
Prime account and your Twitch account
there giving us a couple free extra
dollars every single month it doesn't
cost you a single thing
doesn't cost you a single thing to give
us monetary support so thank you for
everyone over there that is
resubscribing because you do have to
resubscribe every month the directions
to link your Amazon Prime account and
resubscribe every month on Twitch all
right the Tony michaels.com it's like
the fourth one down it says uh link
Amazon and Twitch account
it's really simple really simple really
great I want to also thank everyone who
has joined Discord holy [__] so I
I didn't know well I knew the link was
broken Robin's been telling me that the
link was broken for a while
and everyone's been saying Discord
Discord Discord I really didn't know how
popular Discord was until I got the link
fixed and there's like a hundred of you
all of a sudden this morning
on Discord so if you want to join the
Discord and you want to join the
conversation we're going to have more
conversations over there about the round
table of democracy a lot of people are
excited about this round table of
democracy it's insane it's insane the
round table of democracy is going to be
hot
we've already got a couple workshops in
the works we have one recorded you can
go to the playlist tab on YouTube and
see you can see some of the Roundtable
democracy meetings that we've had so far
one of the workshops on fivecalls.org a
way that you can learn how to make phone
calls to your reps on fivecalls.org it's
a great website I plan on having Nick
O'Neill doing a workshop the founder of
fivecalls.org he's going to do one with
us in the coming weeks I've said other
people
that I'm working with to do these
workshops if you want to find out more
go to the patreon go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or go over to Discord
where we're going to be talking about
this stuff and it's not gonna it's not
gonna take anything you go over to
Discord and talk about this stuff
it's a great way for you to learn how to
engage in your democracy I get your I
get your your feels up your cathartic
outrage here every single day right and
we need to aim it somewhere and I always
say engage in your democracy over and
over and over again it's a theme
but I've never given the tools so we are
going to give the tools in these
workshops and I have so many great
people over on patreon helping me
develop this thing that's right if you
want to help develop the workshops come
over to patreon go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels and you can help develop
these workshops but if you don't if you
can't join patreon don't fear don't fear
if you can't join patreon it's not a big
deal we're gonna make these workshops
public to everyone so everyone's going
to be able to watch these workshops in
the public
it's just on patreon they help develop
them the audience the the members they
helped develop the workshops what they
want to see who they want to hear from I
mean we got great ideas like how to do a
text campaign uh emails we're gonna
we're gonna try to find some email
scripts go over email scripts try to
have someone on to tell us why we can
email where we should email and how we
should email how often we should email
we're going to talk about talking about
registering voters in different states
I'm going to find several people that'll
tell us about that we have great ideas
to have David Pepper on Mark Elias I
don't know if I'll get these people but
I think we will if we create enough stir
and this thing gets popular enough I
know they're going to want to teach you
and educate you and give you the tools
to engage in your democracy
I'm just the guy who pushes the buttons
and knows how to make the screen work
and I'm a pretty good host
it happens you know what I mean you know
what I mean so go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels to find out more about the
round tables of democracy or or you can
subscribe to the YouTube channel right
now
go to the playlist tab you will find the
round tables of democracy playlist tab
there
and you will find that playlist of
ground table of democracy there's
already a couple videos go ahead and
watch them give us your suggestions in
the comments no idea is gonna go
unlooked where you're going to look at
all these ideas we have now until until
forever to engage in our democracy so
we're going to continue to do the
workshops we're going to continue to
make them better and better and better
and I know you're the best smartest
brightest audience and that's what I
appreciate you about you most it's not
only do you come here and engage every
single day you're here every single day
the entire time but you are some of the
smartest and brightest out there you
have the best ideas you're funny yeah
sometimes your mind gets in the gutter
but hey there's nothing wrong with that
when we're trying to have a fun with
politics and we're trying to make sure
that people know exactly what they need
to know it's Tuesday taco Tuesday August
1st Texas Paul is with us you know
because it's Tuesday Gabe Sanchez is
going to join us for just a little bit
today and he's on for the rest of the
week so you're gonna have to get your
game time in today
you're Gabe the guy with the last name
Sanchez you get that time in today so
don't miss it don't go anywhere don't
touch that dial as they say on the radio
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
but it's really cool because I can talk
to you over there you can talk to me
over there like literally I have it up
on my screen right now and I'm watching
like I can watch during the show what
you're saying the comments that you're
giving over there chatting
you're chatting on YouTube You're
chatting on Discord you're on Twitch
we're on we're on the up wire Channel
you're over on Facebook posting comments
again why do you think I say this
because you are the greatest most
engaged audience you really are
there's no one that holds a candle
listen there's about there's about 1800
people watching right now live
1800 people and you're chatting in like
10 different places and people are just
popping off
there's no there's no chat more engaged
than this it just ain't gonna happen and
the reason why is because you're the
smartest audience in the world you know
what's going on how you've been watching
the show for a long time and if you're
new to the show if you're new to the
show you're you're gonna have a great
time here there's no question about that
you're definitely going to have a great
time so go ahead if you're new to the
show go to the YouTube channel if you're
on it right now hit subscribe hit the
like button I'm trying to get better at
YouTube I'm trying to get better at it
I'm just I I just I just don't see
myself as a YouTuber you know what I
mean
like some people like oh do you have a
YouTube channel like no I have a show
and I I put it on YouTube
I put it on YouTube I put it on all
kinds of places
we have a show uh people are wanting to
know where the Discord link is here's
where the Discord link is all you gotta
do is go to the Tony michaels.com that's
thetonymichaels.com
the Tony michaels.com
go over there here's what you do you go
down and you'll see Discord server you
just hit that link it'll take you
straight there
you might have to you might have to
download the uh the app if you want now
I'll tell you I know you don't want to
learn a new app but I'm going to learn
Discord I made a commitment now everyone
wants to go over there and talk and chat
off show which I think is cool yesterday
everyone was talking to each other off
off show in the chat I'm gonna continue
to do that I want to talk to you guys I
want to interact with you guys we're
going to set up different um
different channels on the server so that
we'll have different things we can talk
about like different topics I think I'm
going to do that so come over to Discord
and I know it's a new app
but even if you just join our server
it's worth it because you're going to be
able to talk to the entire [__] fam
over there it's it's gonna it's gonna be
great
um and and they're they're engaged I
mean they're messaging right now I've
got 23 new messages in the last
15 seconds
so and I think I think we'll start
broadcasting over there eventually too
once I get it figured out I gotta figure
it out so we'll broadcast on Discord too
so you can like watch it live over there
too now I apparently I understand the
Discord you can't save the videos it's
live and that's it so if you want to
re-watch you'd have to come back to like
YouTube or or twitch or Facebook
something like that because you can
watch on all those channels you can
watch on all those channels
um where all that is so you can you can
go to you can go to you can go to
Facebook at the Tony Michaels you can go
to Twitch again go go follow us on
Twitch twitch.tv Tony Michaels you can
watch us on the up bar go to upright.com
it'll take you to their YouTube channel
also you can watch us on Twitter I
wouldn't advise it because Twitter sucks
periscope's horrible at Tony Michaels
pod but you want to subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
everyone's saying where is Gabe in the
Discord chat where's Gabe wow
Gabe will be here soon let me let me let
me make sure I think he's gonna be here
at the top of the hour for a little bit
hey ready for top of our
they are asking
almost like he's more popular than I am
on my own show
oh speaking of people who are popular on
the show it's Tuesday which makes it
Taco Tuesday but Texas Paul Tuesday
Texas Paul my friend how are you this
morning my friend how are you Texas ball
I am wonderful I am absolutely wonderful
I am just absolutely
loving the Devon Archer stuff that's
coming out oh my God I am gigantic isn't
it oh yeah yeah because you know I love
I love political strategy I love the
dirty Behind These the scenes stuff that
nobody talks about and this is
this is the Republicans actually making
their move
um and it it clears my path on what I
need to be doing and I'm just I'm I'm
rocking man I'm boiling I'm I'm cooking
I'm ready
sweet why I'm I'm I'm excited too
I'm excited too and the reason why I'm
excited the same reason why I was
excited yesterday because I was
absolutely correct I seen right through
their [__] yesterday morning when
they when all the news agencies acted
like Devin Archer was going to be the
biggest thing the biggest story and it's
not the biggest Story the biggest story
is Republicans keep doing this to
themselves and the media is horrible at
this sexist fall they really are the
media this morning was like who is Devon
Archer what did he say blah blah blah
yakity smackity and it's that's not the
story that's not the [__] story the
story is why do Republicans keep doing
this to themselves why do they keep
making fools out of themselves because
I'll tell you I'm gonna show you this
Andy big slip and I'm probably going to
show it a couple times today because it
Annie Biggs I think I think Andy Biggs
felt like he was lied to by Jim Jordan
and Jim Comer here I really think Andy
Biggs is pissed off at them like super
pissed off that they've been overselling
this [__]
I could get this clip going here hang on
a second
here is Andy Biggs on Fox News let me
get the volume up so you can hear it
that you can barely hear him Texas ball
he just he barely says it because he's
so disappointed listening
do you know anything about that
you didn't know anything about that do
you think today's testimony made it more
likely that the President should be
okay
so there you go there's there's the
attitude from the GOP conference who's
been lied to to I really truly believe
they're being lied due to like Jim
Jordan James Comer and some of these
others have been looked at the evidence
and they're telling their conference
[__] that isn't true and they're getting
people like Annie Biggs in the situation
where he's trying to get to his car and
the media is like hey Andy did the Devon
Archer uh testimony mean anything in the
way of Hunter Biden and he's like no it
actually did the opposite it did the
opposite of what we wanted to do
yeah it it
I'm telling you I I got a thing I was
gonna break on my show Wednesday do you
want me to to dig into it it'd take a
minute or two go ahead yeah okay
they're they are intentionally
downplaying the Devon Archer stuff they
knew it wasn't going to really work for
them they they did there was nothing
there they were going to do the same
[__] that they always do which has come
out and uh you know like Bill Barr used
to do he'd say the this memo says this
this memo says that and and release a
redacted version and you know you
couldn't actually read what the memo
said and then six weeks later when it
was out of the news cycle they'd release
the actual memo and then it would be
just the opposite of everything Bill
Barr said it said
that was that was the the technique but
this is actually just a facet of what
the the GOP is trying to do here you
know you followed all the Biden crime
family stuff and then they then they say
oh man Joe Biden had or Hunter Biden has
bank accounts in China where he
represents people and then you know I
turn around and I chase my tail and I do
an excellent explainer video that yes
he's a consultant he is he works his
company uh you know lobbies for people
it isn't Perfectly Natural that if they
were going to lobby for you Tony that
they would set up bank accounts for you
where you Bank in Missouri
you know I mean this is normal stuff
right but to to the more you know like
the Mario Naval
conspiracy Channel you know where
tim.com still gets on there and talks
about bobolinsky and [__] like that
this is just more smoke in the room more
more [__] thrown at the wall trying to
get it to stick Devon Archer wasn't
really important to them they they knew
they weren't going to get much at it but
they didn't know they were going to get
as hurt as bad as they were they thought
they were going to be able to hide this
Democrats have got Dan Goldman
love the guy they've gotten so much
better about this knife fighting and
that used to be the problem Tony is that
we would never fight on this level and
now we are so it's not working
but it's just anyways I'm getting lost
in the wheat
this is the big story they're gonna push
okay Devin Archer isn't it
Devon Archer was a partner in Rosemont
Seneca what it boils down to is is bhr
the company that they're talking about
bhr was a partnership with four people
it was bohi industrial Investments which
is owned by Bank of China and you
understand China we've explained this
over and China's becoming capitalists
but the government does not let go of
things they've got their fingers and
everything so bohi is owned by the Bank
of China
all right then you've got Harvest fund
and man management which is another
Chinese company they are independently
owned
but with ties to China
the the Chinese government because no
fund massive billion dollar fund is
going to be allowed to operate
autonomously in China it's just not
going to happen you're gonna you're
gonna have big brother watching
they partnered with two American
companies
to work to take over assets you know
there's been huge investment in China
right I mean that's whatever all the
investment management have been
preaching oh you want real growth you
got to go to China
well they needed Vehicles where
International investors would trust them
they needed companies in there and one
of the companies that went in the that
came out of this was bhr Partners the
other two the American companies that
gave them credibility were Thornton
group
out of Boston
and Rosemont Seneca which is Hunter
Biden Devin Archer and Christopher
heinz's company this is why they trotted
out
Devon art Devin Archer
Christopher Hines has
can drop Brinks trucks on them he is the
tallest hog at the trough he he is part
of the Heinz Fortune they will not take
on Christopher Hines directly Devon
Archer is an easy target
he's he's out there scrapping for cash
you know what I mean so they will not
take on Christopher Hines but they bring
in Rosemont Seneca into this dance via
Devon Archer that that's his purpose to
get his name in the news because you've
got Rosemont Seneca Thornton group is
the one that they're going to blow up
next
Thornton group is run by a guy
by the name of James Bulger
that name may sound familiar to you oh
wait wait you see me we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to learn names of
people we shouldn't have to learn names
of again like Devin Archer
oh my god
um James Bulger is the son of Billy
Bulger
who is
absolutely if you're in if you know
anything about Massachusetts politics
you want to be friends with Billy Bulger
he has run the the senate in
Massachusetts like forever he is
extremely well connected nobody's ever
accused him of any crime whatsoever no
corruption he's straight above board he
was the Boy Scout but Billy bulger's
brother was the villain
you want to you want to break the news
to him Tony hello hey Billy bulgers
Whitey Bulger
oh wait wait wait wait in the uh wait I
think I think he's a famous uh India
famous actor isn't that what that is
Whitey Bulger that sounds familiar I
don't know maybe maybe it was a
defendant and a special case I tell
people all the time go see the Johnny
Depp movie it'll explain to you right
right this is an attempt to take you've
got Billy Bulger who really is a Boy
Scout he really is he's extremely well
connected he he he's a great political
knife fighter he is but he's clean his
son James Bulger is clean but
they have the Bulger last name
right so what you've got is and the
Republicans have never needed reality as
you can tell they've never needed there
there the the deal is to spend the last
year telling their voters oh it's the
Biden crime family there's crime there
there's crime there you know and and
Devin Archer comes out and destroys them
he tells them no Victor shocking uh was
owned by barisma and this is part of the
testimony that Victor shulkin was owned
by barisma and barisma did not want him
removed
didn't want him removed at all and here
comes Joe Biden
and he gets Victor shoken uh fired on
the famous phone call uh you remember
that he was sitting there with uh
tongue-tied right now the the then
president of Ukraine and says fire
Victor shocking he's he's a criminal uh
and he says well you don't have the the
cloud to do that he picks up the phone
he calls Barack Obama
and he says you want to talk to my boss
my boss said fire him he's a criminal
you want to move into Western financing
you want to move in Western circles
you've got to get these rats off the
ship right yeah prosecute prosecute
people at barisma if they need to be
prosecuted it's the exact opposite of
what of what the Republicans are saying
detect spot I don't mean to jump in here
but I got I I think I I found an
official statement from the president
United States about all the allegations
of him and Hunter Biden this is just
released yesterday I want you to take a
listen it you got to listen really hard
really fast he doesn't say a lot he gets
straight to the point [__] him [__] them
he gets he gets straight to the point he
gets straight to the point he doesn't
[__] around uh he's just like me [__]
him and our friend Justin Justin Brown
made that uh and he sent it to me
yesterday I was like this is [__]
perfect he said I stole your catchphrase
I said man I didn't mean to own that
catchphrase but I guess I kind of do but
for anyone or anyone who wants to watch
again let's watch it a few more times
this is the official statement of Joe
Biden this may be real I don't know
I think I think it I think it's perfect
I think it's perfect
um and we're gonna keep that uh uh here
handy just in case we ever need to uh
play that over and over and over and
over and over again but we Democrats
Tony we gotta keep me you
folks like Dan Goldman that are actually
elected to office we have to keep
blowing this up [__] up as it comes out
we do we have to keep making them look
like the fools that they are because
they really are trying to paint this
[__] so you've heard it in those lives
you've heard it in those you know like
Mario noff falls groups the conspiracies
that come out will read they wanted me
to honestly honest wanted me to come
last night and talk in his [__] space
they invited me to that space man I did
not have the bandwidth to go listen to
Nick talk about [__] uh the hunter
Biden's lawyer smoking bongs and and and
how important Devon Archer is to our
democracy as if it's some kind of
[__] it's just all a bunch of [__]
nonsense and and honestly I was like I
don't even really want to join in I
don't have the bandwidth to really talk
to these fools let alone try to try to
talk some sense into these idiots I
really didn't have the bandwidth last
night to do it um to be quite honest but
here's here's here's the thing as I
understand we have to keep on these
idiots like we have to keep after them
but you know because because their their
[__] is just horrible Jim Comer and
James Jordan are James Comer and Jim I
don't report sex drives Jordan are
really bad at this they actually Donald
Trump has two of the worst foot soldiers
in history in Congress uh doing this and
I cannot believe Kevin McCarthy gave
these two [__] idiots chairmanships
of committees as one the two most
important some of the most important
committees like oversight and Judiciary
but here these chairmans are on Fox news
on Sean Hannity's show list honestly to
to show how stupid and ridiculous these
people are you just gotta show clips of
them and Sean Hannity even makes he's
trying to make him look good but he
can't but help make him look ridiculous
watch yes or no do you believe that this
is now officially the Joe uh Biden
bribery allegation and do you believe
that you will be able to prove that Jim
Comer
I sure hope so but I do believe it
exactly
that Joe Biden had lied to the American
people
uh Sean and he's like all right all
right shut the hell up shut the hell up
you already ruined it just shut the hell
up that was not the correct answer
that's not the correct answer well the
problem is is Jim Comer James Comer
cannot say that yes this is the Smoking
Gun this is what we will use to impeach
him and the reason why is because they
have nothing so when Mandy Bigg says
they want to do an impeachment inquiry
when Kevin McCarthy says they want to do
an impeachment inquiry when when the
Jimbo's say that they want to do in a
beach good [__] you do it stop talking
about it and do it already go and make
fools of yourselves because it won't fly
on the house floor even with Republicans
owning the majority they're not going to
impeach Joe Biden Texas Paul they're not
going to do it it's not going to happen
they'll have an inquiry and they'll make
fools of themselves so go ahead and do
it I believe what they're doing is
they're waiting for the inquiry for next
year during the primary season that's
truly what they're doing they're going
to try to make sure Trump gathers up
enough delegates that he's the
presumptive nominee and that they can go
after Joe Biden his opponent who will be
the presumptive nominee who already is
the present the nominee if you want to
know the honest truth and they will try
to use impeachment inquiry to smash him
and it won't work it's actually going to
help us because we'll be able to
politicize this at every turn
you know Tony I actually believe it's
going to be their October surprise
I didn't mean next year you mean next
year October surprise okay yeah no I
really do even better even better let's
do that great let's do that but pick
picture it okay you've got you've got
people like that this IRS nobody Gary
shapley that was supposed to be The
Whistleblower That was supposed to blow
the lid off last time
look what they did with him this is a
guy that was such a low rank you know
they they call him a supervisory special
agent but he supervises nothing that's a
title that's a title the ASAC the
assistant special agent in charge runs a
field office has all the executive
Authority this guy had no executive
Authority and he's talking about things
that that you know White House level
conversations that he would have no
privy to uh you know you're talking
about uh attorney general level
conversations that he would not be privy
to they don't have nothing but they
present him and to to the right Wingers
and say this guy knows it all okay look
look who this guy is he knows it all man
he was in the investigation he knows
what right but it's [__] and we
knock it down and we knock it down Devon
Archer comes out it's complete [__]
we knock it down but next October next
October they're going to impeach Joe
Biden and then they're going to have a
hearing and they're going to re-run all
of this crap
pack together one right after the other
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
yes Dan Goldman's gonna destroy them
yeah yes we've got great people in the
Democratic party that are absolutely
going to destroy them
but it's going to be the narrative their
voters want to hear
it is and just like everything now the
information's there if they wanted to
know the truth they could they don't
they just don't and they're going to try
to push it through
what we have to do is keep doing what we
do Tony because we grab the the
corporate media by the freaking tale who
used to and you know you're talking
about how bad they are at this they're
no worse than any other Republican used
to be at doing this [__] it just used to
be that the media would just chat along
any narrative they threw out there the
the corporate media would just repeat it
and run with it and make
Democrats defend against it
they know now that if they do that [__]
we're going to destroy them we are going
to take the mainstream media we're going
to hold them up and say look at this
[__] you know they're doing that to
Newsweek right now
you know they gave they gave Trump carte
blanche to run a bunch of BS and man
they're just they're destroying Newsweek
for doing that
and we have to we have to the the battle
is now Tony the battle is now the
narratives are being the seeds have been
planted they're water in the garden
they're getting everything planned up
for next October I I promise you dude I
promise you we're gonna have to so
thoroughly destroy all this BS
that when they try to parade this
narrative out
which is going to be tightly sewn up
they're going to have it stage ready we
have to be able to just right out of
pull right out of our butt every single
thing that we use to destroy every one
of these talking points
we will win facts are on our side
but we've got to be prepared Tony we've
got to be prepared well you know how we
can prepare and you know how you can
prepare you can follow And subscribe to
detoni Michaels but I'm trying to get
better at this YouTube stuff subscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast right now
watch every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific we're at the top of the hour I
gotta say soon there's going to be a
commercial on Twitch
if you're watching on Twitch and there's
camera because I've seen people say that
comment hey there's commercials on
Twitch there are commercials on Twitch
unless you're a subscriber but if you
have an Amazon Prime account you can
subscribe for free it doesn't cost you a
single extra nickel to subscribe you get
one free subscription on Twitch with
your Amazon Prime account so link your
Amazon Prime account with your Twitch
account and you won't have those pesky
commercials if you're watching on Twitch
you won't have them anymore and we get a
couple extra bucks of Amazon's money
which is kind of cool so you can give us
monetary support on Twitch with your
Amazon Prime account by linking it to
your Twitch account and don't forget to
re-subscribe so if you're watching over
there on Twitch and you keep getting
commercials like why am I getting
commercials you got to re-subscribe with
your Prime account every single month
and don't stop listening to what Texas
Paul is saying because he is correct we
have to keep going on this we have to
keep politicizing this issues we have to
stay on top of these slugs just like
Daniel Goldman set the entire entire
time for the testimony yesterday he
didn't leave once and then he came out
and said this and he gave he dropped the
truth on the Republicans listen there is
not a shred of evidence of a single
conflict of interest of President Biden
ever doing anything in connection or in
relation to Hunter Biden's business
ventures other
then advocating for the removal of a
prosecutor General
who was advantageous to barisma the only
evidence we have right now of any
official action by President Biden in
connection to Hunter Biden's business
interests is bad for Hunter Biden's
business entries and that is exactly the
way that the American people should know
this that yeah Hunter Biden may be bad
but Joe Biden the only connection he has
with any hunter Biden business is he
went over and he got rid of the
prosecutor who would not prosecute the
criminals in honor Biden's business
that is what he did that is what the
Obama Administration did that is what
the UE wanted that's what they wanted
that's what they wanted they wanted to
get rid of the corrupt prosecutor who
would be crawling up Trump's ass and
being his best friend if he was still a
prosecutor if you want to know the
honest truth if you want to know the
honest truth and Daniel Goldman lays it
out there in less than in less than a
minute in about 38 seconds on Newsmax of
all places Texas probably lays it out of
exactly how it should be
um and Daniel Goldman is a star is a
star and and Republicans don't know what
to do with it because they're just not
used to us being in this fight they're
they're just not used they're used to be
able to just say this crap and then CNN
even MSNBC was bad about it right wow
what do you say Democrat do you know I
don't have to defend against that [__]
it's [__] again it's all [__]
we're gonna take a quick break it's the
top of the hour we're going to take a
quick break when we come back hope we
have Gabe Sanchez don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
foreign
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
do you want your own pardon blanket
that's right you can now get your own
pardon blanket I'm not kidding you just
go to store.im Gabe Sanchez that store
dot I am Gabe Sanchez you can pick up
your own personal pardon blanket and at
Gabe Sanchez's store it's store uh I am
Gabe Sanchez get your pardon blanket
today is it is available over there on
Gabe's store you can also go to the
tonymichaels.com Gabe Sanchez's uh merch
store is right there on the website so
go to Gabe's merch store
store dot I am Gabe sanchez.com and pick
up your pardon blanket you can actually
buy a pardon blanket now so go go grab
your pardon blankets today
and support Gabe Sanchez and all his
content and that commercial that
commercial uh is we've been using it for
quite some time now I think he made it
like two years ago this was after
January 6th this is after we found out
that uh people like Lauren bobert and
these others were giving um and Paul
gozard were giving tours
of the capital and people are posting
the the link to Pardon blanket uh over
on Discord God damn Texas Paul Discord
is hunting hopping today we've got like
let's see there's over 40 people that
are live over there we've now got Jesus
we've now got I think over 120 over 120
people on Discord so if you guys want to
go to Discord if you don't know what
Discord is that's fine too don't worry
you'll figure it out eventually
um I'm I'm trying to figure it out over
there on Discord as well I'm trying to
get it together I I don't know much
about it yet but I'm posting over there
and I'm talking to people over there so
I just I just put the uh the Discord
Link in the chat I finally fixed the
link they've been on to me on Twitch
about fixing the Discord link so I
finally got it some people think it's
about gaming I posted the the Discord
link yesterday on Twitch I mean excuse
me on social media and everyone's like
what games do you play Tony that's what
they ask me Paul I'm like I don't I
don't play I mean I I punch Nazis is
that a game like I digitally punch Nazis
that's what that's what we should do is
we should get a we should get a game
going uh punching Nazis I tell you what
another guy that's good at punching
Nazis online digitally yeah Gabe Sanchez
joining us hey Gabe how are you I'm good
and yes I do punch the Nazis in the face
digitally digitally digitally right not
literally I mean magically I I I
probably would like in real life yeah
why not you know
I mean there's a Nazi the thing is x
marks the spot I hear too so it does it
does x marks the spot yeah just saying
you're right I think your mic is
cracking I'm hearing cracking on your
mic is the audience hearing cracking on
games Mike
you and that microphone I swear to God I
don't I don't hear okay now now we're
good now we're good now we're good now
okay I think I think it's good now I
mean it's good as good as you're gonna
whisper into
oh Jesus Christ as good as you're gonna
be
it's as good as you're gonna be what
shut the hell as good as you're gonna be
that's for sure
okay so I want to show you a picture our
video more than that you know over the
weekend they were really upset that Joe
Biden was shirtless on a beach which
kind of doesn't make sense to me I mean
I'm still waiting for my shirtless
my shirtless Trump so right right well I
mean I don't know how many um I don't
know if they stole like laptop pictures
I know they got naked pictures of Hunter
Biden but they get real excited when Joe
Biden takes off his shirt like oh my God
he's got his shirt he's on a beat you
dumb [__] but here's the thing
it's like look how old he is look how
slow he is he can't do [__] he his mind
is going let me ask you when's the last
time you rode a bicycle in Gabe Sanchez
when's the last time you wrote a bunny
so do you remember
um how long has it been six [__]
don't [__] me okay where were you
riding a bicycle at six months ago were
you was it Recreation was it like
necessity like you had to go somewhere
no it was just I was riding a bike so so
you didn't have to ride the bike you
were like you know what I think I want
to ride a bike right yeah I was like
it's been a minute okay the last time I
rode a bike is when my son bought his
current bike I was like oh yeah I can
still ride a bike and I got on the bike
and I could ride it just not that it
wasn't that great I mean I'm just I'm
just not built man when I was a kid
they're very hard I get it listen I I
got my muscle memory back but you know
there's a certain muscle memory that you
got to have to really be good at writing
you can be honest how many times did you
fall over I did not fall I didn't fall
no I I would I would admit it if I fell
on my ass you know me I I'm transparent
here I'll tell anybody anything that's
why I got the mic is possessed
when's the last time you wrote about
Texas Paul yeah uh it's been a few
months ago I've got a mountain bike oh
so you do it for recreation you do it
for recreation you put on about 20
pounds and I got on my bike to go riding
it I heard this voice come book
get off of me what's the what's the seat
desperate for you to get off okay well
that makes sense but here's the thing
here's the thing is that most people who
ride a bike again it takes some muscle
memory like even if you even if it's
been a long time since you rode a bike
you can get the muscle memory back
pretty quick but riding it once like if
you cop on a bike and you haven't been a
bike in a long time you're gonna be a
little wobbly you're not gonna be as
good right you know what to say if you
just write a stationary bike like at the
gym you know right yeah then you don't
fall over then you don't need as much
balance you know and you can probably
gain your muscle memory from like spin
classes or something right yeah okay so
here's the thing I I I I watched the
whole outrage about him having his shirt
off at the beach right and I couldn't
help but laugh that they were freaking
out that a guy has his shirt off at the
beach I think that's funny that's
hilarious now I I would bet that Donald
Trump has never
never been on a bicycle I would put
money on that [__] that his ass his fat
ass has never been on a bicycle so not
only safe to assume Not only would he
not have the muscle memory he wouldn't
even know how to balance on a bike let
alone be confident enough to go to the
beach well we have to we have to
remember that whenever Joe Biden is on
the bike yeah there is always criticism
and actually the one person that always
criticized him is Eric Trump and I think
that is because Eric Trump
never learned how to ride a bike or at
least he tried to learn he was like Dad
can you teach me and then his you know
Donald Trump was like ah get the [__]
out of here right and then he would go
around and be like oh can you teach me
can you teach me like different people
who worked for Donald Trump and they're
like that's not my job I can't do that
so whenever whenever Eric Trump sees Joe
Biden riding his bike like a normal
person right you know out for a stroll
with other people riding he gets jealous
there's Envy there because he never got
to do that he never got to go on a bike
ride with his dad let alone learn how to
ride a bike from his dad so anytime he
sees Joe Biden who's up in his age in
the 70s is looking at a at him ride a
bike he's like ah I'll never be able to
do that and he probably won't ever teach
his kids how to do that or maybe he'll
try to hire someone but Eric Trump is
always the first person
to criticize Joe Biden about riding a
bike which again is a totally normal
thing that people do it's a weird
Obsession it is a very weird Obsession
to get triggered about but he always
gets upset
well I'm gonna show you in this this
video might trigger him then because
here here is here is a a president of
the United States riding a bicycle
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr President
[Music]
and also his wife in tow on a bicycle so
not only does Joe Biden ride a bicycle
and you heard the crowd there because
that's the other stupid [__] thing
that they were saying about the beach
it's like no one came up to him yeah
because Secret Service was surrounding
them good luck with that yeah
not only not only is it difficult to run
on Sand right like as is but imagine
trying to run at Joe Biden or away from
Secret Service good [__] luck right
what what you watched in the video
yesterday because I showed it where a
bunch of people are passing because
they're sitting off off the waves right
they're sitting on and I I'm not a beach
experts I don't know the [__] lingo
right I don't I say Surf's Up
[__] but I don't know [__] about
the beach the reason why I say Surf's Up
is because we surf Twitter and we surf
the Internet for these things that's why
I say because I said all the time I
honestly thought it's because you were
like [__] hanging ten every day man
no I mean
listen listen I have never surfed in the
ocean but when I was a kid I grew up at
the Lake of the Ozarks and I would ski
and slalom almost every weekend that's
right I would ski I was I was damn good
at I haven't skied in a long time
probably 15 years I was pretty goddamn
heavy so it's hard to pull yourself out
of the water when you weigh 270 pounds
especially when you're you know you're a
weak noodle like me like I was I'm
getting better I'm getting lighter I'm
getting stronger so I might go skiing so
I bet I could surf my ass off I'm not
saying that I can or I can't but here's
the thing is that when you're watching
that video of Joe Biden on the beach
there's people walking along the beach
along the water and Secret Service is
like standing there they're like all
right keep it moving [__] keep
it moving you're blocking the view
you're blocking the view and I mean
every time the dude raises his hand to
point you can see an MP5 hanging
underneath right right exactly and
here's the thing is that Dr Jill Biden
and and the president Joe Biden they
weren't the president and first lady at
that point they're just trying to enjoy
themselves they just want to relax for a
couple hours on the [__] beach like
normal humans they don't want to be rage
tweeting about their criminal [__]
indictments they can't be bothered by a
bunch of [__] pressure of Jack Smith
uh Fanny Willis Tish James the Manhattan
d8 crawling up their ass and sending
them to prison they just want to relax
right oh wait that's not him that's the
other guy that's the other guy that
wouldn't be caught dead on the beach
with his shirt off the [__] out of here
man with their outrage and that Joe
Biden doesn't have people who love him I
mean Joe Biden doesn't have people who
want to see him and that Joe Biden is
some kind of feeble feeble dementia
ridden old man he can ride a bike and
I'm here to say that it's a difficult
thing to do because the last time I rode
a bike I wasn't that great at it yeah
but also so you know it's it's not only
um
seen Joe Biden without a shirt on the
beach and everybody like oh my God look
at this guy he's [__] dude how old is
he right now 70 80 what I I don't know
how old is dirt how old is dirt that's
how old Joe Biden is just a few years
younger than 80 80 years old all right
yeah he's eight so 80 years old November
20th is when he turns 81. so he's he's
got a another birthday coming up but
when you look at the comparisons that
people like Benny Johnson makes and
they're always like oh my God uh What uh
what is this this guy's disgusting how
could he how could he be out there look
at his so far dude the dude's [__] 80
man he's 80. here's the thing that
happens when you get older there's a
thing called gravity you know your
metabolism slows down everything gets
just droopy okay and if you're 80 and
he's in I would say in decent shape for
someone who's 80 years old and the fact
that he can go on for bike rides this is
the same thing when they were like oh
Obama's playing basketball and working
out oh God forbid he has a try to have
some sort of like you know well-balanced
lifestyle I'd like to see Donald Trump
throw a basketball to a hoop oh that
would be [__] hilarious oh my God we
would have we would have memes for years
of Donald Trump you remember the [__]
fire truck or semi truck yeah he doesn't
even know how to drive right let alone
shoot a [__] basketball this guy is
not that's the thing that pisses me off
the most about like some of my family
members and where I'm from and I know it
pisses you off too Paul is it like
normal average country folk how in the
[__] do you think this guy is for the
average working man he's never done
anything that average people normal
people middle class people have ever
done in their entire lives he's the
exact opposite of blue-collar
billionaire that's such a yeah but when
they go when they you know when they did
it with The Apprentice right and when
they go after Joe Biden again you know
they get the people who's like oh he's
got a shirt on oh my God oh my God oh my
God it's like yeah but on the same side
of that we have never seen Donald Trump
without a shirt on and I would love for
you tonight thank God I would love it I
would love for them to make the
comparison and be like this guy's an
alpha right this guy looks great without
a shirt on and it's like like a side by
side yeah why are you guys so obsessed
and it goes you're obsessed with they're
obsessed with male noodles okay it goes
It goes back yeah it goes back I know
but it just goes back to their obsession
with nudity sexuality gender genitalia
like the the only thing they have to go
against Joe Biden considering what he's
done and accomplished in his first term
it's like oh man the real Attack is him
being without a shirt on the beach it's
like that's all you guys have that's all
you guys have you have no Hunter Biden
case we saw yesterday
you know I get it though because I saw
the old video remember the video of John
uh John Kerry
sail boarding
the dudes in his 70s man he catches the
wave boom and I mean he's like 25 feet
in the freaking air man I mean he's just
just letting it all out there and I'm
like in my 50s going oh ow oh ah just
watching the video man I'm like how are
these old guys still doing it man if I
was out there doing half the [__] these
guys were doing
I would need pills for days I mean you
got to roll my fat ass out of bed in the
morning try to get me moving again I
mean I I really am just impressed with
the way these guys I mean I hope you got
the picture Biden without his shirt on I
mean for a guy that's in his 80s
this dude looks good I mean he does I
mean anyways I didn't mean to go on my
rant but I just no no I get it I get why
they're jealous man because I see it I'm
like
[__] how
how I pull weeds and I'm like Oh my back
you know and these guys are out there
mountain biking
you know I mean come on
I I I have to say I I
I'm gonna try to go ride a bike now I'm
gonna go try to ride a bike but again I
gotta I gotta uh again I gotta go to the
official statement Joe Biden's just
released an official statement about
Republicans being obsessed with uh him
being shirtless on the beach
[__] em
[__] em [__] em [__] em so there's the
official statement from uh Joba I can't
I'm gonna use that so much thank you
Justin Brown uh for giving me that that
is uh fantastic I what a gift
um
that that he has given me everyone
should spread it around uh so go go
follow Justin on Twitter I I've
retweeted it and you know you can find
it the video so we might do some more
audio with that too why not and we might
put that on I mean it sounds like it's a
stamp of approval from dark Brandon
it would only honestly the only way I
could make it better would be if he put
on the aviators and then said [__] Em
[__] them okay come on Boom the
challenge the challenge goes to uh
Justin Justin Brown you heard it from
Gabe Sanchez
um
I gotta speak in a video in Clips I
gotta show you this one last night of oh
my God the Nazi Barbie you know I've
seen a lot of these Barbie memes like
the pipe bar pipe bomber Barbie where
it's uh it may or may not be Marjorie
Taylor green or look like uh bimbo
Barbie which is like bobert and some
others so I've seen a lot of these uh
the other one was a drag queen Barbie
which was uh George Santos I think is
what it was
um yeah what what's his what was his uh
drag name Katara yeah Qatar ravage so
it's the qataravash is the drag queen
Barbie
um but I think we should do Nazi Barbie
and we can have Laura Ingraham here is
Nazi Barbie and so if you're an artist
out there and you wanna do that go ahead
you know there's still a little a little
mustache all right well I mean I mean
she if you look really close it looks
like she has to shave the Hitler
mustache every day you know our dad had
mineconf on the uh coffee table Laura I
guess that he would read Laura mein
kampf's bedtime stories it appear
appears that way I don't know just a
just a nice little coffee table book
right well yeah well I mean who doesn't
have mineconf a signed copy of mineconf
on their coffee table to uh I mean yeah
because we definitely know that uh
Harlan Crow right exactly first edition
signed copy first edition okay so here
is here's Nazi Barbie talking about all
the evidence against against Joe and
Hunter Biden and how they're going to be
put in prison let's listen now no one
should really get hung up as sometimes
Republicans are want to do on whether
sufficient proof exists to convict Joe
Biden of a financial crime that's
irrelevant here oh my God I haven't had
any brains he would never have wanted
funds to go directly to himself anyway
it would be better if it all went to his
son or brother or anyone in his family
for that matter as long as it went to a
Biden okay so here's the thing she's not
this stupid okay she's really not she's
not this dumb her audience is this
[__] stupid and she thinks and knows
her audience is this [__] stupid that
hey they're not sure here's what she's
saying hey they're not gonna give us any
evidence because this didn't happen but
you that you should not stop talking
about how it did happen even though
there's no evidence that's what she's
telling me I mean you got Biggs
yesterday coming out of the main and be
like he didn't talk about any bribe he
didn't know any knowledge of that stuff
and we were promised I was so [__]
pissed guys
I was so pissed because we were promised
that that Devin Archer was going to be
the Smoking Gun he was going to be the
thing that blew this whole thing up he
was going to expose Joe Biden for taking
the 5 10 20 100 million whatever it is
the number keeps Rising every day they
told us that Devin Archer was going to
be the thing that brought Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden down to prove that there
was this bribery scheme in place and
yesterday God damn it they left the
meeting it sounds like Jim Jordan
skedaddled out of there real quick and
then you got Biggs who then said oh well
no he didn't know anything about the
bribe he had no information
so now what am I supposed to do Tony now
I've got nothing to rely on in terms of
job well that's that's that's what Laura
Ingraham is trying to tell our audience
hey even though even though they're not
giving you evidence because it doesn't
exist doesn't mean you shouldn't stop
telling the story and again this is the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and they have to prep these people
because these people don't have brain
cells to rub together to know these
things they don't know how government
works they they don't want to understand
how government works they don't want to
understand how like uh facts work but
that's the point but folks the the
dummies that Ingraham is talking to
they're gonna go vote they're gonna go
vote just like just like when they put
this [__] dumbass on Fox News okay so
I've told you this before Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan the craziest
part to me about this this clip here is
that really honestly he he
he should have a white board okay and he
shouldn't ignore having a white board in
his little storytelling time like he
ignores sexual assault when he was
um a college coach he really should
shouldn't ignore the white board that he
needs like he ignored the sexual assault
but Jim Jordan I told you this time and
time again that they do this [__] where
they try to they try to make the story
really complex and the reason why is
because the more complex they make it
the less someone understands so the
smarter someone feels the Dumber they
are if that makes sense I know it I know
it doesn't sound like if you can if you
have 300 attacks a cork board and a
bunch of red string it looks you're a
genius right that's what they want you
to that's what they want you to do
exactly you can connect these Dodgers
yeah
okay well here's the dining and Kruger
effect right on Fox news with Jim Jordan
see if you can make sense of anything
he's saying it says they're having a
board meeting in Dubai on December 4th
2015 after the board meeting Hunter
Biden meets with Devin Archer zolatevsky
and pazarsky the two key guys who run
barisma they meet for drinks during that
meeting they say we need the U.S
government to intervene we're under
pressure from the prosecutor we're
facing pressure in Great Britain because
they've sanctioned and seized our assets
23 million pounds 23 million dollars in
Britain we need some help they make a
phone call to D.C Mr arches I don't know
who they call but they call D.C and five
days later December 9 2015 Joe Biden is
in Ukraine and he gives a speech
starting the pressure on the prosecutor
in Ukraine five days after that meeting
five days after a phone call to DC five
days where they use the Biden brand
according into what we've learned today
the Biden brand was the value Hunter
Biden brought to this business
Arrangement that that took place simply
five years Joe wasn't it and then of
course we know yeah the brand the brand
was totally Joe Biden the guy with the
power and the connections in DC but five
days after that this this conversation
uh takes place this speech takes place
and then a few months later that clip
you just played shoken gets fired okay
so here's the thing is the reason why
they were pressuring the prosecutor
isn't because the prosecutor was
Prosecuting barisma it's because he
wasn't he wasn't presenting and and the
thing is is that this is all this is all
reported now you would have here's the
thing to believe the [__] that Jim
Jordan is saying you would have to
believe that into that listen to me in
2015 Joe Biden planned on being
president in 2020 and when he planned on
being president in 2020 you would have
to believe that Joe Biden's like you
know what you know what I want to make
sure all this stuff is put just properly
in place for when I'm present in 2020.
this is stupid actual ridiculous stuff
Joe Biden went to Ukraine to tell the
prosecutor either prosecute Charisma or
get the [__] out that and barisma if
you're if you're following along is the
company that Hunter Biden was in cahoots
with Joe Biden went to Ukraine to tell
the prosecutor to prosecute the company
his son had dealing with you're not
listening if you're not listening but
that is the [__] facts and Jim Jordan
tells this stupid complicated story to
avoid saying the reason why Joe Biden
went to tell this prosecutor to [__] off
is because he wasn't actually
Prosecuting the the hunter Biden company
verisma
they keep doing that Tony they keep
doing it they tell you something that
happened okay
but it's something that's legitimate
it's the way something works it's like I
mentioned before about the you know
their Marsh green sat there and
explained how Consulting works like it
was a crime
this is how sanctions are relieved
people what do you think they're asking
for when they put sanctions on you
they're asking you to do things like I
don't know fire crooked prosecutors
these are the kinds of things that they
want done when they put sanctions on you
they're not trying to kill you they're
trying to get you in line with normal
business procedures and that's what they
did that's what Joe Biden did he
represented our interest in Ukraine the
the Obama administration's interests in
Ukraine and said fire this guy and then
you've got Jim Jordan talking about this
like it's a crime it's not a crime it's
a success it's exactly what we wanted to
happen
but they frame it to their people and
we're going to hear these freaking
morons all over social media oh but he
man he made a phone call and then five
days later what we wanted to happen
happened and that must be a crime that
must be a crime you know it's [__]
man why me people are so stupid you know
to to give Joe Biden credit here really
honestly five days to get rid of us to
get rid of a corrupt prosecutor that
won't prosecute the company that his son
has dealing with that's pretty that's
pretty [__] fast I gotta say that is
pretty [__] fast that's amazing I
just want to point out that I was
following Jim Jordan along the whole way
okay and the points that I connected was
basically if you listen to every third
letter of every fourth word of the sixth
sentence that Jim Jordan says oh yeah
and you will hear Jim Jordan say Joe
Biden assassinated
JFK Jr oh my God JFK what yeah yeah
definitely definitely not Junior because
Junior's still alive he's going to run
with Trump yeah yeah that's true yeah oh
my God so release the transcript is
trending on Twitter release the
transcript now here's here's the thing
folks here's why this is so important
and why this is totally gonna blow up in
their face is because the people who are
the hunter Biden lamp top the people
obsessed with his dick obsessed with him
being with prostitutes obsessed with the
fake stories about the bribery payments
they're all [__] fake it's all
[__] it's all lies we know that now
because they can't provide any evidence
that it's real but here's the thing this
released the transcript thing I think is
going to leak over to Maga and they're
really going to be pissed off when Jim
James Comer and Jim Jordan don't release
this transcript when the House
Republicans don't release this
transcript we should keep at it and keep
on them I know this feels like this is a
stupid topic to talk about but folks
this is their Achilles heel they are
telling us where their weakest the most
by focusing on Hunter and Joe Biden on
evidence that does not exist this is
their weakest and this is their Achilles
heel [__] pound them with it on
social media me if you find a meme post
that [__] over and over if you if you
can type release to transcripts and
anytime anyone talks about Hunter Biden
you say it was a perfect testimony for
Hunter Biden release the transcripts
perfect testimony for Hunter Biden
release the transcripts I'm telling you
I mean you you have to I mean I think
beyond that is just say what was you
know what was wrong right like what was
what was in there that was so sensitive
and if there was something sensitive
then great you can redact it there's
there's nothing telling you that you
haven't and you can't do that as you've
done previously but we know why they had
a closed door session we know why they
didn't put it on camera we know why
they're hesitant to not release this to
the public we know we know we know and
it's all because the The Smoking Gun
like I said earlier this Devin Archer
this former former colleague you look
even if you look at the text messages
that Margaret Taylor green was like oh
this is it this is a [__] gotcha
moment and what does it reveal it
basically says the opposite of what
she's trying to argue
they have nothing
to their whole case
they made this promise in 2022 before we
had the midterms they made this promise
before they took the majority the very
slim majority in the house but they made
the promise James Comer Jim Jordan
everyone was saying we're going to
investigate Joe Biden the corrupt Biden
family we're going to go after Hunter
Biden
and then we roll in and what do we find
out that each point along the way
they've either lost a whistleblower
they've either recycled information from
a previous support which was nothing new
they've lost a a an informant
and then they're like oh this guy's on
the run but it turns out he's actually a
Chinese spy or working with China in
terms of spy also with Iran as well and
then you also look at this recent one
Devon Archer and you and you realize or
I mean not that we have to realize
because we know but you you look at this
and say this was the final thing that
they had this was the last like bullet
in the chamber
and they shot it and it went off in
their face
but this whole time every step of the
way every promise they've made every
step they've taken it has fallen on a
rake and that rake has hit them right
back in the face
so I'll tell you speaking of speaking of
them rake stepping and of course Grandpa
Poopypants over on true social you know
he's losing his mind over the weekend I
mean he was rage boasting all caps just
talking crazy ass [__] about all the
crimes that he's committed and being
prosecuted for and indicted for and this
morning all he's doing is reposting all
that crazy ass [__] he literally is they
call it re-truthing which is the worst
phrase but he's reposting all of his
crazy ass [__] this morning that's all
he's doing over on trees over here but
he did post this this is hilarious I
want to show you this little graphic
that he posted in this this post he said
should I debate
this is this is
this is what he's this is what he's
posting uh over there he's got Ted Cruz
and Greg Abbott they're not even running
are they
nope and Mike Pompeo isn't running I
guess he's saying those people aren't
running so they're out they're axed
which I don't understand that like if
they're not running why would you debate
them anyways this is this is hilarious
this is hilarious you know I I you know
go ahead go ahead he knows he knows some
of them are like Larry Hogan he's gonna
jump in but he's going to jump in after
the trial starts
um same with it with Glenn Younkin uh
Brian Kemp is going to also and he's the
one I actually worry about because we
haven't been doing a lot
to kneecap that some [__] and he's
going to be coming out as soon as the
trials well let me let me let me give
you some hope here Texas Paul none of
these people are ever going to get
anywhere near Donald Trump and even if
they come out uh during a trial which
the first trial is set in uh it's May of
2023. Donald Trump will already have
enough delegates to be the presumptive
nominee so if if anyone believes that
that these people are going to enter
this race during the trial it's not it's
going to be fruitless because I believe
we're not going to have a trial before
the election that's my opinion usually
mine are right but here's the thing is
that first trial is set for for May my
guess is is when they indict him on the
January 6th we're probably not going to
get a trial into next spring maybe even
next summer uh on that one at the first
trial they'll do a first one and then
they'll do a next one and it'll be
they'll punt it into next year so Donald
Trump is going to lock up Iowa New
Hampshire he's going to start to lock up
these delegates and it's going to be a
presumption it's going to be a
presumption of these nominee no one's
going to be able overcome his delegates
on the first ballot in the Republican
National Convention that's just how it's
going to be that that that's what is
going to happen he's way too we're way
too far into this race because the one
guy that they wanted Ron DeSantis of
course they have him at 12 on this
stupid graphic but I bet this graphic is
as scientific as the polls that they're
quoting and the media is quoting that's
the other thing that's really pissing me
off oh it's pissing me off I can't even
hardly [__] turn on the mainstream
media because they keep talking about
polls listen media hey let me let me
give you some advice
one
change how you're doing polls change it
No One Believes it not even if they're
real No One Believes it number two your
polls are all [__] they're absolute
100 [__] and everyone knows it stop
stop
quoting polls you look like a bunch of
dumb [__] you really do you
really do most people are like I've
never taken a poll why the [__] would I
believe one they do that you are killing
your credibility when you post a poll on
the media even if it's real even if it's
true you are destroying you are
destroying your credibility with your
audience stop doing it unless unless you
change how polls are done if you could
figure out a way for people to trust
polls do it all day long for all I care
but let me tell you something and I'm
I'm talking all the commentators out
there too and I will chastise you and I
will beat you to death with this do not
do not do not show your audience polls
they're [__] even if they aren't No
One Believes them stop showing them
polls just like and and let me tell you
something that's what this guy's gonna
rely on Donald Trump is going to rely on
[__] fake ass polls that are all
[__] rigged up and his [__] favor
and it's what's going to create him to
win the nomination because those people
over there believe anything you feed to
them and you should not believe anything
that's fed to you especially from the
mainstream media from these wild ass
poll organizations I know some people
may not have that same opinion to me but
you know me [__] them I know I don't
give a [__] uh Texas Paul I I know I
kind of stepped in either but wait I I
know I don't think that he's gonna he's
gonna have enough delegates even if he
goes to trial he's going to be the
presumptive nominee they're not going to
take it away from him it's just not
going to happen
that's what they're hoping though Tony I
mean I agree with you 100 but that that
is their strategy that was that was
desantis's strategy that's why he was
such a milk toast little [__] for so
long was he didn't want to piss off the
Trump supporters because he thought
Trump was going to die
with these indictments and going into
trial and you know he he really thought
he was just going to be the natural
catch-all for all those people yeah they
believe it they really believe it and
they're clueless they are absolutely as
clueless as the freaking corporate media
Donald Trump just these these guys jerk
off to Donald Trump they do
that's probably why they you know that's
I like I said earlier you know I'm sure
that they would love to see a shirtless
picture of of uh Donald Trump though
they won't but you know who knows maybe
maybe somebody generated some AI image
of Donald Trump at the beach you know
making little sand castles building a
wall that kind of stuff well I want to
go no it's already happening they've
already they've with this with this
whole Biden shirt off thing you know one
of them immediately ran out and created
some fictional [__] ripped ass body
in the Donald Trump oh yeah Bridget
Gabriel
bathroom has has all the best Trump jerk
off AI that you could imagine she has
all of it over there and Nick Adams
posts that [__] too
um I want to go to another another
failure on the right though uh you heard
you heard that x marks the spot right
and you heard that um um Elon Musk
overpaid for a platform and a brand and
he's absolutely destroying but and let
me tell you something the rakes that
these people step on are just fantastic
and and we we did a thing yesterday
where we explained the sign and the
lighted sign on top of the Twitter
headquarters and how it was how it was
doomed to fail and by the time we got
off the air they're taking that [__]
down I don't know if Elon heard the show
or watched the show and he's like you
know what they're right that's really
stupid I should take it you know there
were there there were another
I want to say a seven to seven or eleven
I forget what the number was there were
another Series so before the weekend
started there was one complaint right
and the one complaint was the external
Twitter sign that they had removed on
Monday
that was the only complaint on the
building by Friday and Saturday there
were three which was there's this sign
on the outside and it's no one approved
this and then that was where they had
attempted twice
over the weekend to be allowed to gain
access to go inspect it right because if
you're going to do this there's a whole
process design you get approval then you
you know then you get inspection uh and
then you get oversight into doing under
any sort of changes or modifications to
a building that was built in 1937. it's
a historic building on Market Street
by yesterday there were another again it
was like 7 to 11 complaints that were
listed on the website from the strobing
effect to the sandbags that we point out
yesterday in their photo I shared
to also there were claims that it was
beginning to move and it was a little
bit uh no wait wait are you telling me
at the top of a building like that when
you when you have a cityscape that
there's going to be wind is that what
you're saying it's crazy it's crazy I
know come on
deep State that's just the Deep State
wine team in the force of wind that's
all lived in San Francisco
very windy you and you're also you know
California it's crazy there was almost
like this really big earthquake that
happened in San Francisco years ago that
caused the it caused the collapse of the
Bay Bridge wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait are you saying there's forces
on Earth that definitely can be
dangerous uh and Elon Musk doesn't
understand it and and honestly here here
is that now it was being taken down here
in this picture but it is down the x is
down
um there is no X anymore it is still
Twitter it's not really X because he
can't use it because everyone has owns
the rights to it he hasn't bought it yet
I don't know how much he's gonna have to
pay for it even if the most the most he
can do yeah the most he'll be able to do
is if you scroll down on the image there
all the way
okay now this this oh this like
rectangular uh over here this used to be
the sign so there's a clock on the
bottom and on the bottom and on top of
it it was on all sides it had the
Twitter bird Larry the Bird and also at
Twitter right so to have the handle so
you're saying that's the only place
you're gonna be able to put X the most
he'll be able to do is add an x on that
listen how are you going to get an x on
here how are you going to fit an x on
here that looks decent the one it's
gonna be a small X yeah no it's gonna be
it's gonna be like at X or just a small
X and that's the most they'll be able to
do and he still has to get approval but
also good luck getting approval after
you just did that [__] appropriately
the guy I can't remember his name Gabe
maybe you know his name the guy across
the street to file the complaint has a
legitimate point the government is good
folks I mean government is not bad that
[__] narrative out of Reagan is
[__] government is good this sign
was bright enough to burn your freaking
retness and there are people that live
across the street this is blazing into
their homes
all night every night pulsating [__]
there's a reason there are laws about
this if you want to sign that bright you
can have it but you have to do the
required engineering it has to be enough
of a distance away from people's homes
it has to be government is good people
it is this was unsafe it was brutal for
all the people that lived in the area
there's a reason we have these laws
there's a reason you've got to go file a
permit and have an engineer sign off and
say this will work I mean this there's a
reason for these laws it's not just to
piss you off and make things hard and
make it so you can't put your new fence
in your backyard that's not it it's for
[__] like this that put a mega
freaking blowtorch on their roof because
they're spoiled little billionaire brats
that have no freaking Common Sense well
someone said I said x marks the spot
earlier but I think I was wrong it's x
marks the [__] I think is what the the x
marks the [__] and I told you this would
happen yesterday eventually elon's gonna
tweet this out he's going to say oh it
was all just a joke the Exxon thing well
he did have he did have a response he
did have a response after it was like
well at this point it'd be three days
ago but there was a response that he had
where he just had an emoji laugh
on us he replied he thinks when somebody
was like the city's trying to take down
the sign and the name that you were
looking for is uh is Christopher Beale
that's the guy that lives across the
street is that the guy with the video we
want that's the guy with the video that
was like this is my life right now this
is my new life that I have to deal with
because you guys are well because this
this company Elon Musk and his fragile
ego has to flash a huge sign that says
look at me look at me look at me as he's
burning cats I mean isn't that him and
his entire supporter base but on top of
that we have to remember uh how people
responded to his video which said
imagine no more this is my life now so
all he did was add a video okay
and what people did
was they attacked him
they attacked him for complaining about
a strobe light that was beaming right
into his house or into his apartment
and was saying oh people are complaining
people are attacking me and people are
saying that it's my problem
that I'm the one who should just get
over it
and all these people are they're all
that they're all the the the Trump fans
the Elon stands all these people were
like oh you know what we got to do we
gotta attack attack attack God forbid
somebody says Ah there might be a
problem here we might want to reassess
this and and maybe you know you wait
wait wait you think the Elon sense think
before they speak come on no no no I
don't think they think before they speak
I think too much credit they it you know
it's just it's just like many many in
the uh in the police force or you know
those who protect others of the blue
lives matter it's they strike first and
then ask questions later right right
they attack those who are opponents of
them who they believe to be political
enemies and then they question if
maybe they question after well I have
someone else just pull that up man
pull that up oh yeah that that on on
Seinfeld Seinfeld episode where where
Kenny Rogers Roasters put up a sign it's
great you haven't seen it um but I I
gotta go to another person who speaks
before they think and I know you gotta
go Gabe yeah we'll tell the audience
tell the audience bye because I know
you're not going to be here the rest of
the weeks yeah yeah give them a bride
show them your your tiny hands and my
little Hands Say Goodbye with your tiny
ends you won't see Gabe until next week
I wish him luck on his Adventure I know
he's gonna go build some kind of secret
antifa cave somewhere I'm I'm actually
building I'm actually building a huge
light up sign yeah that says uh cuck I'm
gonna go put it on the apartment
building so I'm flying to San Francisco
I'm constructing this don't worry I
already got San Francisco so it's the
battle it's the battle of the signs
I got the two billion I've been waiting
on it was amazing I'm so excited I'm
gonna be taking a private jet I'm gonna
then transfer over to a helicopter land
on top of the the apartment building
construct this on there it's gonna be
amazing I guess I gotta ask if you got
Soros 2 billion why aren't you sharing
with us what the hell well I gotta deal
with the don't worry you guys are on the
list
I see how it is once I do this I've been
waiting on my Soros check for like three
[__] years now and I still haven't
got the check and now I gotta wait on
you okay
in the meantime everyone I won't be on
the show but you can check out the
patreon I've got a couple more uh what
was that episode that are coming uh Greg
Gutfeld whining like a little [__] that
people are attacking him which they're
not and then also just going after this
whole the Bud Light [__] is back man the
Bud Light [__] it's not it's been five
months man they gotta [__] move on uh
they want they want cheetocha give them
a Cheeto chat before you leave
okay get the hell out of here have a
good vacation my friend have a good
vacation okay we're gonna we're gonna go
Texas ball we're gonna go to um a clip
of someone who definitely speaks before
they think
um this guy he looks more and more like
Goebbels every day doesn't he every
every damn day good Lord this guy I
don't know if he like puts if he has
like a special cream he uses that's like
an it's like a naughty fascist gerbils
cream to make him look this way but God
damn he just gets there every day
and you know what blows my mind is his
wife that he married and when he was in
the white house he was also a staffer in
the White House
she's not bad looking man well I mean
sometimes sometimes these fascists like
Stephen Miller can really brainwash
people I mean he's pretty good probably
is her self-esteem
I have no idea
I know she apparently I I don't think
they actually [__] they probably did
like he jerked off into a cup and then
they did some sort of artificial thing
I'm just saying this is allegedly I'm
not I'm not putting it out there like
it's real I'm just I mean would you
would you [__] Stephen Miller I wouldn't
I wouldn't I wouldn't stand within
spitting distance of him and I really
couldn't Texas well I couldn't stand
within spitting distance of this guy I
would be too tempted I'm way too tempted
if I'm within spitting distance of this
guy but let alone get naked with him in
a bed Jesus Christ no way no way I don't
believe I don't believe that those those
children were made um the real way it
was an unofficial way but here's the
thing here's the thing Stephen Miller
here is talking about a democratic
Democratic presidential candidates right
and he's talking about RFK and he's
talking about RFK Junior Democrats here
all right now listen to what he says and
I'm sure you can catch what he's trying
to step if you can smell what he's
trying to step in here let's let's hear
it of course again we would
so you and I probably agree with on 90
of the issues but to have people not to
have higher percentage right okay that's
true but to have people who are going to
say what is Big Pharma up to what are
big business up to Why is there
censorship in the First Amendment all
the kinds of issues that should unite
right and left Trump that's not what RFK
Jr is doing not even close he's spinning
conspiracy theories he's dropping
misinformation for Steve Bannon and for
people like Stephen Miller and Trump
listen RFK Jr is Maga full stop 100 Maga
he is a trump supporter he's still
pretending to be part of the democratic
party honestly the Democratic party
should strip him of his [__] official
uh Democratic membership strip him of it
and the Democratic party spit out
statements saying he is not a Democratic
candidate he is not one of us we are not
excited about him running the party
because he is a he is a he is a [__]
No Labels type candidate where he's just
trying to destroy this race and he's
trying to destroy our ballot for
Democrats in our platform and it's not
surprise Rising than a Nazi like Stephen
Miller wants a Nazi like RFK Jr in their
party or in our party and posing as
Democrats because that's what he's doing
he's posing well he's asking for more
more idiot voters like they have on
their side that would believe that BS
that's what he's really asking I wish
there were more are more Democrats he's
not talking not talking about wanting
more rfks he's he's talking about
wanting more idiots on the Democratic
side that believe that foolish [__]
you know I'll be honest with you I wish
there were more idiots on the Democratic
side you know how easy it would be to
like police those people I know I mean
you can show them the Brooklyn Bridge
you could sell them the Golden Gate
Bridge but no Democrats think man
Democrats think I could I could sell
them I could sell them Tony Michael's
[__] them trading cards like all day
long oh my God it would be great and I
said this the other day I think it was
on my patreon because I said look I I I
don't make a lot of money doing this
actually I make less money now than I
did before I started doing this I said
maybe when we get the audience one day
maybe there'll be mountains of money on
that side of it but here's the thing
it's like if I really wanted to make
money doing what I'm doing if I wanted
to make cash today like right now I
would flip and be right wing tomorrow
that's what I would do and all my
audience would hate me and they would
leave me but oh my god there would be
mountains of money for me on the other
side because I can talk into a
microphone I understand that I'm good at
it I know that but I would I would in
the way I look and the way I sound oh my
God I could make [__] millions of
dollars millions and I would out talk
and out [__] do all those right
Wingers on their own platforms I would
destroy them as far as getting
garnishing my part of the market but
that I I that's all [__] I I would
be inauthentic it wouldn't be me so I I
wouldn't do that but the thing is is
that there's more money in the right
wing lies and misinformation that's why
RFK Juniors doing it that's why he's
doing it is because he's getting paid to
go speak at these places he's been being
paid to be a guest at these [__]
shows and all this they all it's all
money all of it is money anytime you see
like um attorney points USA where they
have all these speakers and [__] all
those people are getting paid to go
speak every [__] one of them all of
them are getting paid to go speak it's
profitable for them to spread lies
misinformation and fear that's what
they're doing that's what they're
[__] doing they're getting paid to do
all this [__] they're getting paid to do
it RFK Junior gets paid to go to these
conferences and give these speeches on
his conspiracy theories that's what
happens he gets paid to go on these
shows that's what happens I hate the
burst your boat and as a PSA what Tony
just said there is exactly true
it is exactly true if we both turned
into right Wingers tomorrow and sold
right-wing [__] the money would
flood in it would and it would flood in
from your papa your crazy uncle right if
you have Maga relatives that are up
there a little bit you need to be
watching out for them I mean I know
they're annoying I know they're a pain
in the ass but these people freaking
fleece them I forget how much was it
Tony that that Tony that Trump took in
in fees alone I mean it was like 600
million dollars
it was just a stupid amount of money
that he's taking from your relatives
that buy into this [__] and I mean
that's the whole purpose of it that's
the whole purpose of it is to spend the
lies and spend the grift and have it
there to sell now here's the thing
here's the thing is that um obviously me
and Paul are not gonna turn to the right
but we could tomorrow we could tomorrow
and and there would be there would be uh
lavish lavish huge amounts of money on
the other side like literally literally
the Heritage Foundation you know all
these little uh shitty podcasts that we
that we show these little bitty shitty
podcasts sometimes we get a clip of them
because they say some crazy [__] or like
some [__] Donald Trump's on one of
these obscure podcasts or some of these
people aren't obscure podcast those
people are being paid by places like
Heritage Foundation for their show like
they are giving money to them every
month just to do their show they don't
care how many viewers they have they
don't care what Their audience is
they're paying them to say that [__] and
they're paying them to have these people
on their shows even though they're
nobodies even though they're not
talented they they just have a
microphone they've garnished a little
bit of an audience saying right wing
[__] and the Heritage Foundation will
pump money into their their show every
month and I'm not talking like little
bit it's not like 500 I'm talking like
five ten thousand dollars a month is
what these little stupid right-wing
shows get from places like Heritage
Foundation and the reason why is because
the right wing understands something
they under stand narrative they
understand that you have to get everyone
on the same page
it is super important to do that that's
they they know that they know that's the
case and and listen if if you think what
I'm saying is [__] just go look just
go look at some of some of these reports
of the Heritage Foundation and where
their money goes and a lot of it goes to
media and a lot of it goes to these
little bitty podcasts that Mike Flynn
goes on that Trump goes on and you're
like who the [__] are these people I've
never heard of these people well there's
a reason why you've never heard of them
is because you're not supposed to hear
of them you're not supposed to hear of
them you who who like Paul said use your
[__] brain and you think are not
supposed to hear these podcasts who
hears about them is is grant Grand Mammy
and pepe when they get their email hey
Donald Trump went on this [__]
podcast it was great you should go look
at it and they paid all that money to
produce all those podcasts so Grand
grandpappy and Grand Mammy would go
there and they would buy gold and they
would they would do be part of the grift
because that's all it is is a [__]
grift on the right and that's why I
would never [__] be inauthentic and
do that I've had some people say oh one
of these days Tony you'll be a right
winger you just wait just the way you
look and the way you sound get the [__]
out of here if I wanted to be a
right-winger I'd have done did that [__]
I did not pretended all just like all
the right Wingers pretend that they're a
bunch of [__] Nazis they don't
believe half the [__] they say they just
say it for money so go get [__]
anyways that's my that's my soapbox on
them on right wing media
um
let's see what do we got what do we got
left here we got about five minutes left
Paul give us a give us a plug you got
some new shows coming up oh grandpa in
what is this hey Grandpa in a Barbie
world you get a Barbie shirt yeah oh
yeah man I wouldn't finally saw the
movie man it was great took my
granddaughter to it you know it took me
a while to get there that's the bane of
being a grandparent did you only get
your grandkids when you can get them you
know it's not like when you get them so
it took me two weeks to finally get the
grandkids we went down and saw it
outstanding movie
outstanding it's not just for kids it's
for everybody enjoyed the hell out of it
if you haven't seen it yet go see it
it's a fantastic movie I've got shows
coming out every Sunday and Wednesday 10
a.m no you know you know be there be
there we are rolling the audience bigger
than it's ever been before every show is
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
love to see you folks there I'm glad you
show up
well I I'm I'm happy that you're you're
doing more and more shows and I'm happy
that the audience is getting bigger and
they're listening to what they need to
listen to
um and they need to hear this stuff and
and you're at a coffee uh oh yeah show's
over shows Over Texas falls out of
coffee Texas Paul thanks for joining us
I got I got a few I got a few pieces I'm
pleasure my friend I got a few pieces of
news I want to tell the audience about
here
um you know we've been doing this
Roundtable democracy over on patreon.com
it's [__] fantastic and the the
patron the members over there on patreon
are getting involved they're helping
organize they're helping with ideas
they're trying to get their workshops
together they want us to do workshops we
did on one on fivecalls.org
um and and I have a lot in the works
here I actually have uh Nick O'Neill
who's who's the founder of fivecalls.org
gonna join us for a workshop I think
I'll have him on the show too so I'll
have him on the show do an interview
with him so we can meet Nick ever the
entire audience can meet Nick and then
we'll do a workshop with him now folks
if you're out there and you're wondering
why why you have to be on patreon to be
part of the workshop you're not going to
have to be on patreon to see the
workshop will you make all these
workshops public every last one of them
is going to be public so here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna organize them
and do them in patreon and then I will
release them to the public for you to
see but we're going to do them on uh
email campaigns we're going to try to
get people on about registering voters
in different states we're gonna get
experts on to tell you exactly how to do
all this stuff how to organize when to
organize because I always tell the
audience Texas well I always tell them
engage in your democracy engage in your
democracy and this is one way that we
can engage is organized together but
it's also a way that I can give you the
tools I can find them we can go out
there all the members on patreon can go
out there and find them I can go find
them and then we can show them to you
the audience the world we can put them
together do a workshop make the video
public so you can see it and you can use
those tools because here's the thing I
found out Texas Paul by doing this the
last couple weeks
it's some people are very comfortable
with certain parts of Engagement but
they're not as they're not as
comfortable with other parts so what I
want to try to do is gather up as many
workshops as we can by the end of next
year by the end of the uh the year for
the election that gives you the audience
member rather you're on patreon or not
gives you the ability to say you know
what I'm comfortable with that type of
Engagement that is how I want to engage
that is exactly how I want to do it and
then you have the tools and and you have
the workshop to show you exactly how to
do it so make sure make sure if you're
interested in participating in the round
tables of democracy live go to
patreon.com D Tony Michaels at
patreon.com the Tony Michaels you can
find the round table of democracy there
but listen all these videos are going to
be public so all the workshops will be
public you'll be able to watch them so
if you if you can't be a member of
patreon don't stress you will be able to
see these you go to the Tony Michaels
podcast go to the Tony Michaels podcast
on YouTube click the playlist tab there
will be a round table of democracy see
playlists there and don't forget to
subscribe and like as you leave also
join the Discord Discord server holy
[__] you guys blew up the Discord server
today uh I'm so happy about this Discord
sir right I didn't even know that you
guys would like this so much but there's
like I think we're up to 100 over 150
we're almost 250. so let's get to 200
today on the Discord server go go to the
Discord server I'm gonna put it in the
link right now
go go and it's in the chat right now so
go join the Discord server right now the
link is there the links on the Tony
michaels.com make sure to go over to
Facebook watch the show live at the Tony
Michaels every single weekday on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels follow us
on Twitch it's free to follow us over
there make sure if you haven't
re-subscribed with your monthly Amazon
subscription that you do that now you do
that right now you can go to the
attorney michaels.com to get directions
there also download every single episode
of the Tony Michaels podcast on Apple
Spotify Google remember Gabe won't be
joining yes but I'm looking for I've got
some ideas
for special guest host for bonehead of
the week Paul I gotta get you on one of
these days to do a bonehead of the week
when Gabe isn't here but anyways
audience same time same place tomorrow
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
's meal Barn head ass Beacon
[__] em [__] em [__] em [__] em [__] em
[__] em